[Music]
ok ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
man I have good conversations with well
it's good to see you man I'm glad you
came out we finally made this happen
indeed you know yeah right
you know funny with the comedy business
I feel like you know we think we know
each other but it turns out like
sometimes we really don't know each
other well because we we don't spend
enough time getting down to what's
actually important
you're the nitty-gritty stuff yeah so
it's always hey what's up what's up and
grab-ass
but then you and I once in a while like
we'll be backstage of some comedy
festival I'm like oh we can talk about
what actually matters you know you you
have the same references and stuff and
it just cracks me up
no is a weird thing it's like I always
think that like we're at the comedy club
we see each other and then you know
comics see each other but like and then
real life gets in the way of things and
sometimes you don't know right yeah it's
sometimes you find out Oh a comic had a
baby or yeah or they you know they got
married or some life event happened and
I'm like oh they never told me then you
go well maybe we're not we're not as
close as it seems if you're not in
somebody's life yeah yeah just not but
then what'll happen is there's a lot of
noise as you get older a lot of noise
and and you know things change quickly
at the speed of technology and and
people are making inroads and and what
happens though is you you meet somebody
who's your age and gone through all of
it and you're reminded a lot of this
is not true yeah like it still takes
time to get what you want it still takes
time to become a whole human being and
then you mean thanks a lot we were
talking and I'm just like oh yeah yeah
yeah that's a reminder that there are no
shortcuts there is something like that
what I mean
but then we get caught having I feel
like we have in this era right now we
have one foot in the old school and then
one foot trying to find the step for the
new school yeah you know and it's like
yeah you're mourning you're mourning in
some ways a way that used to be in a way
you're almost mourning your own
mortality yeah I miss the Johnny Carson
time when there are four channels are
there's something about that Mary Tyler
Moore that had an impact when when in
fact a certain kind of genius was
rewarded well you know I in other words
like I was listening in old Fiona Apple
songs
mm-hm say what you will about Fiona
Apple man she had some deep lyrics and
she had a lot of [ __ ] going on but but
now I feel like I'm speaking like an old
dude but I was at the music scene is is
is it's become these nuggets that you
can consume and then it just goes away
okay I feel like we are old yeah okay
specially talking like this ya know it's
like and so like let me take my teeth
out this is the same thing that was
happening like look Aristotle or
whatever wrote like a an essay about the
kids of the time that's true and if you
read that this gotta be relevant today
if we read that article that he wrote
we'd be like oh this always happens
people get old and they think that they
know what's best they don't and we yeah
I mean we don't and it's not it is
you're right I mean I think that
Millennials or whoever you want to call
they know a lot of them are searching
for meaning and purpose - yeah they're
just feeling their way out cuz the
world's moving fast for them - but I
think if we we talk like this like when
we think about like you mentioned music
so I feel like when you look at music
and you go all the music of today they
don't know how but that every generation
they say that yeah you're right you know
they just they keep saying the same and
there was a lot of junk back then
there's life right now right that's why
when you do we know what really messes
us up is when we listen to those
stations like 80s on a tour
Andie's on nine or 70's on seven so when
you listen to those kind of serious
stations the problem is they're only
playing the hits that's true so when you
listen to that station you might think
this is what music was supposed to sound
like yeah because they're only playing
the time - oh very true of every you
know to me when aid that the a sides but
but to push back on that a second and I
think you're right about that but I I is
it but it went back in the day and I
might be wrong but let's just take
someone like Marvin Gaye lets him take
um there was in a lot of ways the notion
that music was somewhat revolutionary
right so so you you had an ability to
change the world a little bit right like
like it was either like so so let's just
take someone like Miles Davis Marvin
Gaye whoever the people who grew up
black in the 50s the 60s and the 70s
where as a man you really couldn't
express yourself without some danger to
your person right okay but you could do
it through your music uh-huh right
I don't know and I'm not saying that
they're there I'm not saying that Steve
there's no revolutionary music and I'm
not saying that's the idea and there I'm
by the way I don't even know what I'm
saying but I I wonder if because there
was fewer options to become successful
that it's sort of like it does that mean
it a better condensed the best and so
you had a Marvin Gaye do we have today a
Marvin Gaye a Led Zeppelin a Miles Davis
I don't know if we do I I don't know
okay I'm not pushing back on what you're
saying is maybe if technology was as
advanced as it is now yeah if there was
as many outlets as there are now back
then yeah we would have found that that
there were actually more than one Marvin
Gaye's huh you know that's it that's
that's fair you know so it's like with
the there's something I was listening a
couple of strike at the streaming
service on my car yeah I don't know
music man I'm not I'm not qualified to
be talking historically about music but
there
is some from what I can tell there's
some good songs out there man yeah well
I mean I know what you're saying but
it's like like I don't know how we how
do we stay relevant like like who tells
us that this is what you should be
listening to right now so I think back
in the day you had no choice because it
was like here's the one radio station
that's on you know that yeah the one
rock station the one whatever station
and they were always playing the hits
yeah and that was the only way to find
it's just like with television that like
you knew what the number-one show was
because it was like there was only four
networks and and everybody's talking
about mash so you look like you had to
watch mash yeah but now with like a
thousand networks you know that so it
becomes diluted right but what I'm
saying is there's a lot of great stuff
we just can't find it yeah that's okay
you know but but is there a lot of great
stuff or is it is there is there less to
push against I'm asking is there less
than push against then there was say in
1974 and does that have an effect on the
artistic expression of the day well no
but if you go to a billboard charts say
go to Billboard charts go look at say
the top hundred in 74 I bet you there's
like 50 of those people you're like I
don't even know who that is
who's this person I don't know sound so
dumb the same there's probably [ __ ] in
every era like instead of thinking about
like like the great because it's what
we're talking about if I did great you
know you're right when you have a
limited number of radio stations
you are gonna it's going to get only the
best is gonna rise right right
it's like back in the day when you get
Carson as a comic it made your career
well nobody did that five minutes man
you you were you know yeah yeah no now
yeah what are you books what do you want
make a dent what do you think I know is
I know doesn't make it yeah yeah it
would be better to to do it on Instagram
yeah you could yeah look at what's
happening to people I just had someone
on my podcast amanda cerny she's this
internet person and she's worked her ass
off from being a Playboy Playmate to
like now 25 million followers you know
just like got I've got a fitness thing
and I
what I find is that we like I'm just
gonna count us as like a little
old-school era but we're in this
transition where we're not quite like
we're not quite like that era where like
you know they were coming up in 80s and
they were like oh my god we were making
three grand at a triple run yeah we
missed all that yeah okay so we're in
this era where we're like we're trying
to make it seem like it's supposed to be
back the way it is but it's not and we
can't figure out like why it's happening
the way it's happening now that's a yeah
you know and then we're doing these
things like like um look how your life
has changed from a podcast I know I get
some maize like hopping on TV for 13
years okay in this pocket my small level
of success in this podcast game which is
very small in comparison to like fodder
indicating Chris and Co but people come
to coming to my shows now like hey man
love your podcast so I'm like what you
know so it's like try to accept this new
way is weird
well I've never been I mean the podcast
I started it by saying cuz I was
watching Rogan sell tickets and I was
like I just wanna sell more tick but me
too because TV wasn't doing it which is
crazy and is that hard to accept yeah I
mean I'm doing school yeah it got picked
up for a second season I guarantee it
has a minimal I mean I might sell three
tickets yeah yeah but my podcast but
your podcast makes you famous oh yeah a
podcast for like it definitely keeps you
relevant people go oh you're Bryan
Callen I listen to you on the fighter
and the kid so why haha
that's where well what do we get 800
thousand downloads and episodes it's a
lot of people yeah well for me it was
like I knew something was up because I
I'm always a podcast guest I'm on every
I do everybody you know and I was like
sold the first time I did Rogan I was
like I said to Irvine improv that
weekend that was the first time I'd ever
gotten bonuses at the Irvine improv yeah
you know then that's what I knew I was
like oh I got started podcast that's the
bump yeah I was like it was like that is
an amazing like a you know cuz because
you know it cuz it's direct-to-consumer
correct so there's that first time in
history yeah the artist has a shitload
of power yeah we can make all the money
it will help you start a podcast with
Will Sasso right
and we podcast you're gonna do
[ __ ] just I mean what's funny
about how about this how about I give
you this no III will do a TV show and
and everybody wants to sitcom yeah you
know it's amazing I get I'm probably
gonna take a bit of a pay cut you know
good good how about that well I'll be
working 12 hours a day on my feet I'm
very grateful to do it right right I
mean consider at work it's maybe even I
love everybody I work with but what I'm
saying is technology has made it so I
could spend three days a week doing a
podcast yeah and doing the road yeah and
I could make more money yeah
what I know what well then and my agent
just network said that's gonna happen to
you yeah he said you you're gonna get to
a point where you're where TV's gonna be
a pay cut yeah I was like oh yeah you
were CA yeah Oh will it same here yeah
and I've been I've been grinding for 25
years and you tell him I know you tell
me now now I know but see that's the
hard part the hard part is like you go
you see a goal you see like you have to
do it this way you got to do it this way
you got to get on TV and all this stuff
anyways yeah all the sudden he just goes
anybody can like you know they're like
oh I want to start a podcast and like
get some fame and fortune real money Oh
25 million followers that that's
millions and millions of dollars yes she
got your houses she got a house and [ __ ]
and she just started a podcast herself
her name is what amanda cerny all right
it's crazy you know what though you know
what's funny is like okay say ten years
ago what people were doing was like
these actors and stuff from they would
state they would start doing stand-up
because their agents would be like hey
miss a lot of money in stand-up you're
famous you can get people to come to the
things they're bypassing that now yeah
now they're like I'm just gonna do a
podcast yeah look at the Will Ferrell he
just was like somebody must have came to
him and said did you much money there
was in podcasting just do Ron Burgundy
or whatever and now immediately it was
like number one podcast Conan getting
that competing with Will Ferrell he's
phenomenal but look at Conan Conan - he
started his podcast now if he came to
you like hey do you want to come on my
show you might be like oh can I can I be
on the pocket so true
what do you want three minutes on your
show or how about we do a pot how do we
secretly talk to me for an hour on a
podcast and and that's really taken its
toll on celebrity quote unquote because
it used to be celebrities would come
down from the from the mountain yeah and
you get five minutes of what Arnold
Schwarzenegger was like you'd be like
yeah yeah I know I know you know tongues
how are you to read a magazine in the
supermarket like as you're in line you
go ooh look what this has to say yeah
now you're broke and you know you're
doing a podcast yeah I can I'll learn I
have to read the book I can just listen
to do talk for three hours anybody I
want I have access to the best that's in
their brain and the funniest is in their
brain and I think I think that's what it
is to our realize like with the it's
just weird thing you know when your fans
or whatever come up to you and you're
like oh man I love your podcast just a
witty say you give something like this
is fan art you know no man you know it's
just like it's weird it's a weird thing
yeah and I just have a picture of you
holding a giant fish yeah is that a
salmon dude I did a movie and they made
that come up with a story just lie to
people who's on hose I was like I don't
think fisherman I'm not even like oh now
you you there was a level of respect
that you started their rows in you for a
second like this guy I didn't know this
guy should lie to you'd be like yeah
that was a pounder off the coaster like
some weird place every five pounds I was
a Herricks holding that thing I really
and look at all casual walk
with his flight you didn't wrote that
thing in with your glasses on I think we
stopped picking apart my can apart the
lie how dare you by the way I like the
pulp fiction movie poster yeah you know
I'm trying man like you know I just like
I say I don't have a I don't have a big
studio like fighter in the kid and like
you know you know I got might need it
that's the thing that's I'm saying you
know yeah cool fake brick background
I've been bobbing building you know each
week you know I have a wand yeah you
know what I was in I was in Nashville at
the club in Nashville yeah and one of
the waitresses like she heard me talking
about Harry Potter and she comes up to
me like hey I actually make wands and
this again I was like okay and then she
brought me this so I wish I knew her
name it was like isn't that great
I make wrong yeah she had a widdle bat
[ __ ] down
what a hobby right I want I'm a won't
make us any more it's like you sea-doos
practicing tightrope park yeah
still you gotta [ __ ] you go to work
right now young man I know you're not in
the circus I know but what do you think
about first of all were you from
originally
well that's a good question I remember I
was try to get people's origin stories
I'll go through my well you want to know
this is my life until I was 14 okay born
the Philippines really militaries
mmm-hmm banking military moved to the
father was in the military my dad was a
marine okay you know so your Filipino
born in Manila moved to India where we
lived in Calcutta and then Mumbai where
my sister was born it was Bombay back
Wow then we got and then we got moved to
Lebanon this is every two years
oh geez not then Pakistan oh my god and
Lebanon again uh-huh
beautiful Lebanon was the war look out
stuck in the war it was gonna be a
earlier than that sir everybody thought
was gonna be in Oh 75 okay everybody
thought it was gonna be a quick war
turned into a 35 years of war we get
evacuated to Greece
Wow two years in Greece than Saudi
Arabia oh my good Ryan very severe Saudi
Arabia sorry Reba still of this old - 14
years old did you go there yeah I've
been in Saudi Arabia yeah it's the worst
really yeah yeah so are these guys will
go we can get into Saudi I love the
people but it's it's a it's a tough it's
a tough place yes it's uh place to be so
tough place to live well hobby Islam
it's a very puritanical oh my goodness
it's a there's a there's a real
adherence to that you know and it's an
oppressive regime there they're new
their new king is not a good guy not a
good guy have any of them been good guys
and somehow the United States can't
bring themselves to condemn this [ __ ]
they've done in Yemen and everything
else but forget all that but the point
is is that so I'm 14 and my schools they
don't they don't allow those foreigners
to go in to high school there so I go to
boarding school in Massachusetts for the
first time oh wow I moved to the United
States never lived in the United States
how'd you have school but because your
dad was in the military you had American
citizenship because of that my father
was a banker he worked for a bank but it
also probably did a little work for the
military as well so but but you know so
then then there in Saudi Arabia I'm I'm
in Massachusetts going to boarding
school Wow summers in New Hampshire
where I go to summer camp there's
nothing else to do I can't go back to
Saudi Arabia and then um and then I go
to college in Washington DC for four
years oh well American University and
then I then I'm New York over seven
years or whatever and then I'm now I'm
100 years old by the way I'm 27 I get
MADtv this show called MADtv as an
original cast member don't belong
they're not ready for it not good enough
to do it everybody there I've been doing
sketch for way longer than I had and
somehow I find my way through get fired
after two years and then spend and then
and thus begins the journey yeah of Los
Angeles and sitting in traffic and
hearing the word know over and over yeah
yeah but finally you know at 52 I'm I'm
internationally known and you
and I'm sure it's very exciting to have
me in this room so so where am i from
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you're literally the only guy the only
comic that I know that I'm totally okay
that it can be on 24 hours a day but
you're the only one I take that as a
comment it is a huge compliment because
there are guys that like you know you're
around them and they're doing a thing
they got their stick and you're kind of
just like hey man yeah turn this [ __ ]
off well because I think sometimes you
realize that's all there is and you and
I seem to talk about what's important
yeah just have a way about you that's
like it's always like I'm like damn good
I'm doing like what he's doing right now
it's great you know again I'm a fan of
you I'm a fan of your work
my favorite credit I've won if I ever
bring you on stage is always like from
Reba it was a great show which is one of
those weird shows that I was like you've
been on so many things
you know so but you know it is what it
is and here's your journey so now here
we are right now so but what do you
think about the business in the last
like two or three years with everything
that's going on socially like you know I
think how it's affected you know like me
- yeah Trump like all these things that
have you notice how does it affect your
performance yeah I think so if you look
at the if you look at the fact that you
can't say the f-word when referring to a
gay man now yeah that used to be an
acceptable prejudice if you look at how
being gay is no longer to be crucified
on the playground yeah in high school or
in the workplace you don't have to keep
it a secret that came out of the AIDS
epidemic that the plague that came out
of the war that a lot of people attea
and remember this but gay people went
through [ __ ] hell
and a form of a halt
cost all due respect of course to the
Holocaust yeah but but but but for real
man and I was in New York and I watched
men die and go through this terrible
crisis and I'm sorry it was a war they
were decimated and and it was a horrible
it was a horrible disease that robs you
of your dignity you starve to death
you've got weird lesions on your body
it's horrible and you were and you were
hit with it in the in the prime of your
life that galvanized a community to
fight back to unify and to be heard and
that's where will and grace which I
always content is one of the most one of
the revolutionary shows it was we didn't
have a gay show and Will and Grace broke
that mold and all of a sudden with gay
people were brought into your living
room every week and we fell in love with
him Andy Dick would say that he was
first but Andy Andy Dick a sexually
ambiguous god bless him but he would say
that means that type of character on
television he was doing before yes yeah
well probably and he was and I worked
with him when he was doing that
character on the [ __ ] was his - his
first show Network and now I was called
um remember with Joe Rogan and soul mate
Oh Oh on the news radios radio great
show yeah but um so so my longer point
is this so now now we have the me to
movement uh-huh and I don't I'm not
comfortable with it I'm a guy I'm a dude
in a lot of ways yeah yeah and I and I
felt too threatened by it in a lot of
ways I was nervous I was worried you
know it's like I've I'm done I don't I
can't I start taking start taking
inventory of all the times that you do
that I say inappropriate have been you
know have said the same thing hash tag
I have yeah without an end but it didn't
dawn on me man it like it didn't I'm and
I'm a old man yeah and and what it did
is it forced me to look I started paying
attention yeah to what women actually
deal with yeah you know for like and I
just believe in a meritocracy I'm not a
feminist I just believe in if you got if
you're [ __ ] good for the job I don't
give a [ __ ] what you just may be
confident I'm about am i I'm about
things being a leader system
yeah the best yes I'm starting a
business and and I don't give a [ __ ] it
does not matter what you I can tell you
I can show you who I'm gonna about to
hire alright its diverse but I'm not
that's not because I'm bi just know
they're funny and good right but at the
same time though at the same time though
the push back on that
yeah on what our cuz I believe the same
thing I yeah you know I even talking
about this marquee of competent yeah and
it's like I believe in elitist I believe
that's why Sports is great because you
know you're never gonna you can't you
can't [ __ ] with sports correct you know
say these are the best but the point is
that the pushback is that the same
opportunities aren't presented you know
well and so so so I think like things
like the me to movement and things like
these some of these things always go too
far the nature of any revolution is to
eat its own young mm-hm and create what
Obama called a circular firing line so
that's part of the growing pains right
Rob of people kind of go and hold the
hold on hey your pendulum swing been
dealing with this [ __ ] yeah forever and
I actually do think that when you're a
boss and let me let me just explain how
it's subtle um I I hooked a friend of
mine up who's a beautiful girl with
interviews and the guys that was all
dudes it was a sausage fest and the dude
asked her out no he didn't give her the
job but she what was she gonna say yeah
yes and you get the job no and you don't
know you can't prove that you part right
you just can't so if you have a boss and
he asks you out when you're working with
him and you need that job he may not
fire you but depending on who that guy
is you may pay a price in a very subtle
unprovable way okay
so in a way I understand I understand
how this movement has put people on
their best behavior yes because I don't
like the fact that you can get accused
your you can be ruined by accusation
right but it puts you on notice and it
makes you more thoughtful it makes you
more thoughtful it makes you realise you
you and I've I've done this where I'm
way more way more aware
and the the the what would start it with
fear but now I'm I'm a more aware of
what somebody goes through and I don't
like being a bully and I don't want to
create an environment where people can't
fully express themselves you understand
and so that's the positive side of all
these progressive movements yeah I got
my own problems with the left you know
but I also think it's needed and I think
anytime you have social change you're
gonna have crusty [ __ ] like me
going hey I'm getting left out what do
you mean I want more straight white guys
on Netflix and doing specials I'm funny
well okay but well know that I also
remember being 28 29 with women who were
40 had been doing it forever and I got
us I got a special
I got Letterman yeah I remember a really
great comic who's a woman she goes did
you get Letterman she was like Jesus you
I wish I was she didn't mean it this way
but she was like I wish I was a 28 year
old good-looking young guy and it's true
yeah me too right yeah because my
pushback on like like like these
movements is that you know that they
have to remember like like I don't like
when women look at the lineup of the
Comedy Store and then they tweet out
like just no women on the lineup
and my thing is like meta been at it for
a long time first of all well not just
that because my push back on it is look
at the lineup closely it's also mostly
white like don't take away from what I
had to do to get on there it's not women
versus men now you know it's like a bow
traditionally was a there were a lot of
black comics but it was for
traditionally it was started with the
Jew Jewish borscht belt it started with
the Catskills it started with the Jews
the Jews invented the American art form
known as improv and Sam Wasson wrote a
book about this called Improv nation
this started in Chicago with Russian
immigrant Jews who were helping children
who were underprivileged
express themselves okay so so you heard
it here first talk about white you don't
conflate please don't conflate Jewish
people with white people it's it's
offensive you don't if anybody who says
but you see when we're doing this now
you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about pick up a history book you
dumb [ __ ] because it's it's it's
so historically offensive you were when
you were a Jew up until I don't know 30
years ago it was you weren't getting
into businesses and if you were a Jew 40
50 60 years ago 70 years ago that's
[ __ ] a blip that's a blink of an eye
in the history you were rounded up and
killed you were kicked out of Russia and
everywhere else so so and that continued
and continues to this day
yeah if you're a Jew I'm not Jewish but
I'm talking this way if you're a Jew you
are you comprise point one percent of
the world's population
so don't conflate [ __ ] being Jewish
with being a straight white male you
don't know what the [ __ ] you're talking
about so we get where everybody has
their story that's what I'm saying
everybody has their so I don't even know
what your nationality is but what I'm
saying is in the comedy game that's why
I believe in that you say I believe in I
already yes because what ends up
happening is everybody could say
something because if you look at a list
you could be like well there's not
enough Mexicans there's not enough
Asians there's not enough this so how do
we decide it's gotta be the best well
with the way it do you decide as you let
them you let the marketplace because
what happens is there's money to be made
in stand-up now you're gonna have a lot
and you do have a lot of Hispanic no
whatever the more Vietnamese Chinese
korean-american you're gonna have Arabic
and you do you're gonna have all these
people who are like man I can be funny
too I mean I'm the class clown right
it's just self-expression and there's
always room for original self-expression
there is always room for another fresh
off the boat there is always room for a
when's when are we gonna see an Arabic
sitcom I want to see what it's like to
be an Arabic American you know you gotta
watch out Rami on Hulu yeah really
really really great how you know he's on
there he's like he's like a Muslim
millennial hey on the show is the based
off his own wife it's a-workin crew
welcome to what it's like to be Muslim
no we're working through what it's like
to have you know a lot of a lot of young
men be terrorists from other countries
who in the name of Islam how do you deal
with how do you negotiate that it's part
of the American [ __ ] we're messy in
America huh
let him feel messy let it let it be
messy let us figure this [ __ ] out well I
think with all this stuff that's
happening as we're talking about this
it's like again it's thinking I think
it's made as a comic you you have to be
just more thoughtful you can't just your
punch line just can't be she's got big
tits so whatever the thing is or it's
like you know yeah actually it's mate
you know so I have to really think about
this you can say it but for the most
part people people are like it's okay
I don't think exactly I don't think it's
appreciated as much as it was before
yeah we're just kind of like a put a
bullet left whatever I don't really
think I ever always try to avoid that as
a I never liked making fun of people and
I never liked I never liked get yourself
the butt of the joke yeah I mean I guess
I do the man [ __ ] but it's it's all
tongue-in-cheek yeah but again but
tongue-in-cheek to us to somebody out in
the audience might be like oh here's
another man saying some man stuff
although that's rare I know I think that
you that we're hearing the Twitterverse
is not a good example of it's really not
good first of all that doesn't represent
America now it's just like some like
elitist people who like you know and
then we can we look at that as like oh
this is what people think and it's
actually not yeah if that's what people
thought and uh somewhat like it's like a
different president it's like this comic
I know I looked at his I looked at his
somebody showed me as they were saying
some stuff about him they show me his
Instagram he's got 400,000 plus
followers now I was like he does that
doesn't make sense and then I saw that
his videos had 6,000 views right and I
was like this dude and the person said
he bought those followers and I'm like
that's not a real following yes and so
Twitter's kind of like that Twitter's a
little bit like that where where it's
like that's not really a good that's not
a real good metric for the the the
American mood I know but unfortunately
in our business they rely on it so much
well [ __ ] corporations why because
every club doesn't how many times every
club will hit your hand you're coming to
us in a couple weeks can you tweet in
can you put up a video it's a good side
of that though too because we don't have
to do as much press and you can become
your own PR I know I get that but it's
like what did they do before like what
they do before well the social media
like how did people do a magazine
articles or the newspapers are calling
or they act like there's no other way to
get people to come to the club other
than social media but now nowadays it I
feel old says now that you know think
about this now they want you to do a
magazine my first question is is it the
cover of time because I don't know if
anybody gives a [ __ ] right magazine
but then like it's gonna be connected to
a website yeah but even that is like and
the website will have I mean if you put
me out of Twitter or of a magazine
that's in every airport in the country
maybe I brag all right I guess that's
sort of you know I'm sure I saw one
there's nothing worse than seeing actors
who are just they just they got ready
for their cover of Muslim John John this
John Johnson is that's gonna be you you
sixty and steroid it up this guy used to
be kind of hairy now is shaved and brown
shiny I think that I think steroids huh
maybe technology's gonna advance to the
point where it's good like already they
have creams I'm just wondering like it's
gonna get to a point where it might be
like CBD oil you know you just go a poem
thing and then your body's gonna feel
great well you do have that you can rub
there is testosterone cream but they're
gonna have some gene editing [ __ ] I'm
waiting in line man I can't wait well
they're saying right now that people's
bodies this is the first time in history
that the body is out living the mind
yeah well that's where were you know to
interchange parts you're gonna be able
to print tissue you'll be able to print
organs
well what they've what they got to
figure out is like what's going on you
know in our head the deterioration of
the brain they are yeah that's what I
were they're reverse engineering the
brain I hope so cuz like you know like
I'm my mom's at a point right now where
she's dementia is kicking in and it's
just a shame because she's a you know
still a vibrant woman you know to me but
it's like what do you do
creatine apparently help is a little bit
helpful and even seasonally and all that
kind of stuff but it's like it's what
I'm saying it's like like like you know
it's like they go like we're if we're
who wants to live longer if you're gonna
like I don't want to be a hundred and
thirty now and then be like 130 I think
about when you say that I think I would
learn how to play an instrument fluently
I wouldn't master the piano yeah but you
you wouldn't be able to get the
arthritis and your fingers no you
wouldn't even be able to play all right
so yeah you're right
yeah this would mean like you're like
what it like what happen where are we
blowing my fingers I have to work yeah
you're gonna be like you can't even you
know you're but already don't you
already feel like you know cuz you're
still an athlete you're 52 still a
athletic guy you know your box you keep
box okay whatever I still go to that
place I like that place but what I'm
saying is like you know are you already
at that point where your brain is
telling you you could do something and
your body's like Brian come on well I
did this video for Julia and I was
hitting Mitton and I was like and I when
I saw it I was like gosh wait I did the
same thing so the you know they tape you
sometimes they go you know so I'm doing
it okay and in my mind I'm cuckoo cuckoo
clock like [ __ ] these mitts up right
and then like I saw the video and it was
it was like a palsy hand a father time
I'll be like I will get beat up on the
streets man father time wrong yeah I'm
the only undefeated well and wisdom is
sort of that notion of coming to terms
with your own limitations and making the
best of it beautiful about embracing
your your I guess the fact that you're
running at a road yeah this is like it
is what it is I remember I had this
young friend of mine and he always wants
to play basketball and so I still
thought okay you know so I'm going to
play with him and I was like it I was
like oh my god
like like he just was stronger and like
you know just zipping by me and I was
like oh that's it
that was like that was my retirement
well that's why I read my mind I walked
off the court like my trainer wants me
again the rings sometimes with you like
like it like God logan paul he's 24 year
old yeah yeah and he boxes and he was
joking around me goes let's spar brian
and my back of my mind i was like i mean
i spar a lot I was like I would and I
was like wait a minute this kid is and
then I looked and I was like this kid is
big yeah he's a big kid muscular yeah
and athletic and knows how to put his
body behind his punches and I was like I
can't [ __ ] don't do that yeah dangerous
for exactly the point hit me like he
could hit if I make one mistake and yeah
that's me on the side of the head I got
I mean I might have fainting spells for
the next eight months right I can't do
that [ __ ] yeah it's not well what's not
for me sir not for me like I go yeah be
a silly goose prime like I go to boxing
just to uh just for the the workout
right I'm trying to go to like you're
not trying to get to trying to get to
the ring like no that's like that's way
get out of here Brandon Adams who won
the he won the contender and he was nice
enough to move around with me not spoil
me just hey Broc him move around with me
joking around
yeah never hit me he's just a good and I
hadn't been doing it for a long time but
I was so gassed but I remember being mad
I was like damn cuz he was just doing
whatever and my buddy goes excuse me
come over here for say world champion 26
year old profession yeah yeah you're not
you're not you're 50 year old man what
you're not you're not suggesting that
there is in any way that you don't think
that you a shot they do anything you
will we do think that I think you have
to have late first of all you have to
have a little bit of delusion or sweet
that's what keeps us going but you don't
want to be in there like even I am in
there like you know what test me right
after you every lean boxing you on the
street just looking at people like you
don't sleep those late father's I'm
gonna hit this pivot foot my father 75
year old by my buddies 75 year old
father on them on full court basketball
clan by basketball tried to fight a
young man they had to hold him back he's
75 right bro I know
hey man come on now and a proper young
person is gonna be like come on
old-timer look at you know to me or it
might be a
a young person who didn't have a good
relationship yes Father or just have no
respect for my elders yeah yeah yeah I
just I don't know our dudes out there
who are like oh that's just reminds me
all the trauma cuz my dad used to hit me
I just think I had to save my shoes on
because you wake me up when he was drunk
not you but do you but have you ever
have you in your adult life have you
been in situations where you've had to
like go to the jujitsu how you've had to
go to the boxing skills not have you
yeah not for years you're right right
right well especially when I wouldn't
right and I would I would I'd figure
something out
like drive really fast away I know
exactly what you're saying man like you
know it's like hey if I'm with my kids
and you come at me I'm gonna cry right
you're gonna lose an eye but otherwise
yeah I always say like for me I always
think to myself like if I have to get
into some fight if somebody's coming at
me I have to I have to say to people hey
you're gonna have to kill me
yeah because I'm not gonna just I'm
gonna come at you you're gonna weigh
your headlights crap yeah I'm coming at
you you would tie your style man like
I'm not gonna like I have to protect my
[ __ ] this isn't gonna go this ain't
gonna end we're not putting my dukes up
and slip in your shots but in my mind I
train because I'm getting ready I
realize that I'm writing jokes about
this I realized that at the end of the
day I'm always getting a little bit
ready to fight for my life uh I know
what you're saying I'm always afraid I'm
never relaxed yeah why is that oh you
know this is also the insecurity of
being a performer and security being a
human being and being 170 pounds 511 and
you know I mean I you know I don't know
cuz I'm a I'm a [ __ ] balloon and a
forest of pins just being a human being
being a human one imagery how long would
you last you can't be you know you're a
balloon and a force of
you're it's easy to kill you like if you
say like I'm a little of gasoline that's
funny you wouldn't last it's more you
knew we obviously need to find a better
analogy you're better than that you can
you can toughen your skin a little bit
so you don't so you can scrape those
thorns okay okay but you know yeah we're
all going down no I I understand what
you're saying man yeah you know but like
um what do you think about being at the
Comedy Store right now like I think it's
never been better
yeah I mean no it's probably been better
but we're Buber back well it's it's you
know it's the best comics in the world
you and I are lucky enough to be at the
you know we get those spots when we want
I totally agree I feel like in 10 20
years they're gonna look back at this
era and I'm gonna be like hey I'm glad I
was a part of that yeah man but there's
just amazing things going on right now
and I just think what a combination of
who your favorite comics I'm simply the
combination of podcasting
yeah with podcasting a social media
everybody comes and then this right
what's happening at The Comedy Store
it's just it's an amazing place in
people's ears yeah it's working you know
moving boxes we're in the working man's
ear that's who's listening I know that's
true you know everything is going on
we're both great friends with Chris
D'Elia you know what I mean and I just
think that what Chris is doing right now
is uh it's it's pretty incredible like
like a second amazing like you could
write a book about it like just the rise
in social media its social mean just
just just collecting a fan base the way
he is so engaged with his fan base that
it's a new way it's almost like another
lane it's a new lane of like fame and
fortune it 100% I mean it's never been
easier to make more money with less
effort but he owns he owes his career
mean yeah
nobody does more with less yeah I wanna
say you're welcome Chris because he's
there's no crystal here without the kid
you know I'm saying what it was a hard
for you to watch that happen know
no no Chris was undeniable yes that's a
very hard for you me too I mean I love
that kid and I'm better but also when I
saw him at Carnegie Hall I was like
Carnegie Hall and I were watching him
before anybody knew him and Neal was
like oh he's gonna be and he's just
undeniable yeah yeah and and I was like
and then I said to me like I just want
him to read more cuz I want him to keep
this going and I want to expand his
expression I do these weird things and
you know he's an innocent leave him
alone [ __ ] he lives to make people
laugh that's what yeah yeah and he's
undeniable I mean yeah it's like he
doesn't get I don't get um I've never
felt who that guy is doing better
that's a scarcity way of thinking and
it's also false I just uh but it's a
when it's a friend of mine like that I'm
just I get so excited about it I know
exactly what you're saying is I feel the
same way but they're still also is a
healthy level of like envy it put you on
bushes you yeah put that's all I noticed
yeah yeah yeah I like Santa I learned a
lot from watching Chris and Brendan and
all these young dudes who were doing
social media right no I learned I was so
resistant home now I just don't know
exactly what you saying about be
resistant grow again I was watching
Rogan he was always a social media beast
yeah and I was like [ __ ] all this I
don't want to do well it was called
self-promotion and I felt weird about it
yeah but [ __ ] all that no because again
stuck in the old school way of like no
this is how you do it you get on TV you
do a late night show people stood the
clubs and support you and then now it's
just like no there's like you know and
I've realized I've realized that you
know um as we're talking I haven't
posted in about three days so I got a
post I know you know I got my agent
calling me just funny can't talk when my
agent calls me he's like hey man you
know I'm looking at your Instagram and
like you know you guys you know you
gotta be more like CEO you know all
feels Instagram art is this Justin no it
was a Ryan over there you know it but he
says right but what I didn't appreciate
like healing did see so I looked at
deals and I was like um you know it's
like I don't see what you're talking
about in terms of life
No Deal is so I was watching he does
that podcast with Shaab and goddamn he's
funny yo can do some fun he was just
roasting people he's just a weird yeah
he'd makes these Corollary yeah yes good
damn is good yeah so then again another
person that we're seeing like like in
this particular in this era of the
Comedy Store is great to watch the the
rise you know the work so hard you know
he's so unique but he works hard he very
unique yeah really hardworking guy yeah
he's very considered about everything he
does I've seen it yeah you know yeah cuz
it's like he hates himself but well join
the club you gotta have yeah thank you
you gotta have a little bit of that do
you can't have you should have low
self-esteem if you're a comic yeah
there's no way they do weird work and
then we have to be able to deal with
like the no all the time so that you
gotta love yourself man no you have to
be a little bit of like I don't love
myself so I had to keep improving then
we net that we never finish correct you
know then you just get to a point where
you're so old that you're just like I
never improved and then you look back
you know how to say my career I feel
like my career I'm on a treadmill and
it's set to one incline you're a turtle
okay and so then I'm going I going and
going but then when I turn around after
a while I go oh I actually have done
some things well but I don't notice it
while I'm which is why you should never
your metrics should never be in
comparison it should be in comparison to
yourself and where you came from right
not in what that guys doing cuz that's
weird math doesn't stack it doesn't
translate anyway because of likes people
like I always say there's no right or
wrong way I would say people that want
to do comedy they think they look at
someone and go oh I want to do exactly
what that guy did but it's like it's not
gonna work that way cuz that guy did it
yeah you know so now say what's your
lane and it and there's so many
different lanes right now yeah you know
it so it's just like finding that Lane
and and being authentic and true to
yourself but that's that's actually the
hardest part about being a stand-up
comic it's being as authentic as you can
I agree I mean I think that the mission
has always been for me original
self-expression that's simple and that
never that challenge never goes away
you're all
yeah you're always trying I love it I
mean right now I've I've really fall in
love with writing again is after
shooting my special complicated Apes
I've ever done but I suck at re-roof tea
yes a criticize Reba III but I felt
empty housing I don't know how to write
anymore winning what questions am I even
gonna ask well you know I always find
you to be someone that is like right on
the edge of like especially politically
your political beliefs are like in if I
feel them in in flux
all the time in warring with like what's
going on with like this sort of black
and white culture that we have like even
though we live in the gray area I have a
joke about that I say if you'd never
vote for me for president because I'd be
like I don't know sometimes maybe it
depends yeah and and the more I learn
and the more open I stay I am right wing
I am left wing I am middle it's just a
pen it really does depend the more I
learn about something the more respect I
have for like just that me to thing or
or a lot of my problems with the left
and stuff well yeah if you didn't have
the left you need both yeah
and you can sit where where are you are
you like just just let just write of the
center or just like right right to you
are you always gonna source all around
there exactly so and so I believe in it
can't equality equality of opportunity I
don't believe you can socially engineer
equality to it to an extent you have
anti-discrimination laws those are
important but I don't think you go into
boardrooms and say not enough women here
I think that's the dumbest well it's a
Marxist idea and I'm vehemently against
it and and any kind of Marxist ideology
i think is lacks creativity doesn't work
and is ultimately oppressive however I
also think we are in a period of time
where pure capitalism ie making
shareholders wealthy and not reinvesting
in research and development just to take
an example of a kind of an economy and
and business
is terrible yeah and it's short-term and
thinking and managers have a lot of
pressure to make shareholders wealthier
and so they'll they'll make decisions
that are not long-term so you're not
building things to last necessarily um
and and so I don't know if that creates
real wealth I don't know but there are
intelligent arguments that would suggest
no so there there are a lot of these are
not Republic these are just ideas so if
you're not absolutely right run just
talking about a problem that that when
you have any time you embrace an
ideology hook line & sinker
whether it's libertarianism whether
which I like a lot of or socialism
you're in trouble
mm-hmm you better be a verb you better
be in you better be responsive to the
evidence be willing to change your mind
don't root in an ideology don't root
into a team don't identify self identify
because by the way when you say that
you're a Republican when you say or a
Democrat when you say you're a hard left
those ideas were given to you you didn't
come up with those ideas you are
parroting you are aping a lot of ideas
that were given to you by your parents
by your community by your culture your
religion and politics so if you get to
usually that starts at home it's up to
you to to throw I'm quoting Nietzsche
[ __ ] basically but shut that off
don't be a camel be a lion and men
invent the invent a moral and ethical
philosophy that here's to who you really
are
yeah and then the only way you can find
that out is you have to live you got to
live have respect for traditions that
have been around for a long time because
because the judeo-christian ethic the
Islamic ethic the creek ethic and moral
discourse has a great deal to offer
don't throw the baby out with the
bathwater I know that respect it
understand that has some offer and then
and then find your way man yes right
find your way find your way yeah no I
don't know I completely agree I mean I
just think that this is a
what's happening in the world right now
like I think having Trump as president
you know it should make people wake up
to like what are your real thoughts
about you know politics like what what
what do you want to see happen and how
involved do you want to get in into it
you don't get yourself involved with
politics that politics will find you get
involve itself with you that's it
because what will happen is if you have
an authoritarian strong man in power and
your democracy starts to slowly erode
institutions don't mean what they used
to etc well you're gonna wake up and by
that time it'll be too late so so Civic
push back to anyone in power it's very
important this is exactly it's a
responsibility as an American yeah but
like I say like you know you get this
voting thing in the mail now you know
you get it like and what I realized
though in the last election is I'm
looking at this and I'm thinking to
myself I don't even who are these people
like what is this about is this enough
information this little Panther that you
get for voting I don't know if it's
enough information and then with the
with the we're inundated with this like
with social media and like you know
what's going on on TV to tell us that
hey this is what's supposed to happen
what I don't even know it's true right
you don't know if it's Russian BOTS you
don't know what the [ __ ] is going on
dude look at leave no dead even look
there's four three things that I don't
think should be for profit okay
education health care and the news I'm
gonna push back a little bit on that and
also this should be for profit yeah but
I'll push back a little bit but I I
agree with you on the news I think it's
like the famous story when the 60
Minutes the editor-in-chief came in and
said good news bad news good news is 60
minutes just got amazing ratings bad
news is six minutes just got amazing and
now you have opinion you have opinion
makers which is not so new Ralston Sean
hey just looks like to do yeah Don Lemon
these people are concerned with their
ratings they look at their ratings
they're not looking GT ge and whoever
their corporate sponsors they got to
make these people happy and they're
speaking to an echo chamber they're echo
chamber already agrees with them you
can't
you can't actually challenge the Fox
narrative because your ratings your your
your viewers will be like hey you're
saying [ __ ] I don't agree with yeah well
dare you
so that's not real objective news so I
agree with you there I think that
schools we do have a vibrant educational
community I'm just a should pay for
itself is what I'm saying well well to
be made there I just worry that yeah
there is a lot of innovation that goes
on in in medical technology and things
and a lot of that is for-profit venture
capital funded and I I do think we're
seeing the fruits of that labor so we
have to be careful with there is okay
well the profit motive but I agree with
you on Prince okay look agree with
working like health care for yes okay
this is what I'm saying about health
care yeah you have the MRI machine
that's right they have the machine at
the hospital okay like charging people
$6,000 from MRIs yeah what is the point
in that I'm just saying that the health
care that's that's you know I'm just
saying to the model of like how they
make money I'm not saying like I want
doctors to make money I want me but I'm
saying I think there's a way for it to
pay for itself where it doesn't have to
be like to me there shouldn't be
somebody sitting in a mansion someplace
making a million dollars that is never I
wipe someone's ass in a hospital because
they caused a because they like a
pharmaceutical and all that comes down
bigger the bigger house insulin I how
people dying because they can't get
incidence and I don't want to live a
society like that we live in a society
like that so I'm just saying that's what
I'm talking about it where I feel like
my friends a doctor they couldn't afford
cancer drugs and he said what do I do
and the doctors did go home and read the
Bible you didn't know what to do yeah it
was crying so there are stories like
that and I think none of us wanna live
in a society like that I think the
bigger threat is that politics is for
sale you know well doesn't it what does
it not been for so I think it's worse
now I think that now when you have
congressmen who spend 70% 70% of their
time calling
fundraisers calling money sources
calling people that give to their
campaign and they do it across the
street in their car and they have a list
of donors when they're doing that when
you have when you have real problems
with Americans but what's being debated
on the floor of the house is swipe fees
for banks because they're lobbying
effort and there are so strong when you
as a politician basically have to say
what you're told and not what speaks to
your conscious ya options that's where
we have a bar we are now in Washington
DC this is an economy of influence this
is an economy where you know being a
congressman is great for six years but
what you're really gonna do is this 160
grand is [ __ ] you're gonna go to K
Street in about five six years and use
those contacts and work for a lobbying
firm make five times that much money but
if you think about it how like I'm not
surprised that look at our industry and
how technology and being an influencer
and all this is like affected our
industry why wouldn't it anong affect
other industries as lasya Cortez you
know okay Cortez using social media you
know took an incumbent who'd been there
for I think twenty thirty years yeah I
mean he was entrenched yeah she kicked
him the [ __ ] out right and there are
even Trump himself even Trump himself
like you know he saw what was happening
and like you know his he had a great
campaign people they thought it was
funny yeah they put this what I say on
the Trump Trump was fun to call right he
called the guys sat at a debate I mean I
don't like the guy and I've said this
many time he's the closest to an
independent president we've had and he
is in what I like these babies China
personally I think China I think China
is awful in a lot of ways I have big
criticism China I think they are I think
they are immoral II I mean what they're
doing right now to the Yeager's which is
a Muslim minority and rounding them up
and they are putting them in
concentration camps they're liars
and they're immoral and what they're
doing and that's a small example that is
a totalitarian I don't care what I'm oh
yeah they're free right as long as you
don't say anything against the
government as you you do what you're
told and and you're WeChat is monitored
and you are a car you better be a
card-carrying communist so [ __ ] off and
I like that he's they don't have fair
trade practices they do engage in which
we've allowed you allows you guys want
anything like yeah we want everything to
be cheesy I realize I do like that he's
like you're ripping us off no more and
let's go let's go let's have a little
trade war I know this is bad for the
economy I'm not an economist I'm being
general with this right do what a lot of
enjoy but the point is that the dudes
funny the dude you can't help but could
be like What did he say
I know if the Democrats put serve is a
great politician he's a great politician
and if the Democrats and the economy is
doing really well in a lot of sectors so
if the if the Democrats put someone like
Elizabeth Warren up against him you
watch what the [ __ ] happened be another
ass Democrats are so unorganized they
kill they're eating their own I'm a
self-hating little right you [ __ ] you
need I'm telling you I said if you want
to compete with that dude I would
suggest to this time around I'm sorry
everybody get get a dude who's had
military service like a Navy SEAL who's
smart and big and and got a biting wit
yeah guy who did team sports I can roast
you that gig have him stand with Trump
Americans yeah
you'll get all those Trump voters I
promise I'll be like I'm go with that
guy cuz I like him cuz he actually was
in the military yeah all you got to do
with Trump is go listen you're actually
a you're a big fat [ __ ] at the other
day you're not you never did really you
play basketball but you didn't do
military service right and also you're
not that rich you're too afraid and
you're not an American you're a trumpet
you're for trumpet Stan you're actually
for Trump a Stan cuz you're on earth you
can hit him with those things there are
some he does have an Achilles heel your
Bob and then you gotta be funny and
Biden's trying mad Biden's [ __ ] that
Angie I know but socks I know
take him he's out there he's trying to
stop go get four will Obama light that
dude with these had a shot [ __ ]
finds the Joe Biden a I'll bring back
Obama a dip [ __ ] Americans are gonna be
like I had six hundred dollars in the
bank [ __ ] get out of here I'm making
more money now so no your no on Biden
the Biden's the dumbest idea he'll get
he look like he might win the nomination
good good he's not even in the same area
code yeah he'll give lip and stuff and
and Trump will be like what you do
you've been a politician for how long
you're a career politician [ __ ]
yeah yeah and you cheated on your and
you plagiarized your your college or
your law school things at this point who
cares about that kind of stuff
well I mean me Trump is already like you
made it worse like if he can be like hey
whoa I guess what what's the moral stand
that's what to your investigation came
out with [ __ ] oh don't even give me say
you know what I you know what I knew
there was nothing is well first of all
when the lawyer okay so you got the
lawyer he's he's going to jail yeah he
has nothing to lose Michael cornea and
he says nothing he says nothing I was
like uh-oh you know what I thought it
was like to remind me of that scene
uh-huh everybody that's seen a godfather
to you know yeah they're doing the the
Senate hearing and then in walks
Corleone with his brother yeah they're
Frank pantangeles all like you
misunderstand me it was almost like :
like Trump walked in with his brother or
something cuz I was like this guy's not
saying anything he's going to jail says
he has nothing to lose it seems you know
and that's why Cohen they found they
found his brother in it yeah and he was
slow my favorite scene is like
Corleone's like getting patted down to
come into a print and he's just looking
at him you know he sees his brother and
then he has that look where he's like
okay alright you know okay oh but I feel
like it was something like that I just
don't get so what okay when I saw that I
was like I said I was telling my liberal
friends prepare for the Muller report to
actually have nothing biting
yeah like yes what's in there already is
enough that the president shouldn't be
involved in this kind of [ __ ] but it's
not enough apparently to get Congress to
go lesson peach the guys listen and
Conor and the Democrats have to let go
of the Russians didn't get Trump elected
you dumb [ __ ] that's the dumbest the
Russians will be helped to do that
laughs [ __ ] all that the Democrats lost
Hillary Clinton lost that election she's
gonna won that [ __ ]
and the Democrats fair enough I
shouldn't put Hillary Clinton up in 2008
America told you didn't like her right
put her back up there nobody likes her
little trust her it's a weird it's a
weird so you guys know that's why I
think Bernie should go away [ __ ] yes
he's a social why is it crusty whoa he
has vacation in the so he took his
honeymoon in the Soviet Union do you
know that beautiful place yeah he
honeymooned in Russia so you wonder a
Russian collusion well that was when
they were communist he already got
outplayed by someone that got outplayed
by Trump so like why I have this guy
again like that let's get out of here
right at all but just a model report man
I just feel like I always said I have a
joke where I say like like cuz Nancy
Pelosi a couple months before it came
out she was out publicly saying hey I
think we need to stop worrying about
impeachment less let's let's worry about
the election because I think she saw
Muller out of Starbucks and he was like
[Music]
if you need two years to investigate
something you don't got [ __ ] angry you
know I always say they should have got a
woman to do it like a woman found bin
Laden okay that was a woman yeah all the
woman needed was like Trump's phone and
like a deep dive on Instagram and this
[ __ ] have been like
like I'm just saying like they should
have got out cuz women are more
meticulous just more you know more
patient with investigating things like
that so I don't know I just think that
but anyways they are still harping on
that and a damn while they're doing that
the right is still galvanized like you
know there's not enough of people to go
I don't think I like him anymore or the
economy if the economy stays where it's
at
Trump will be real well then now this
like abortion is like a huge issue
that's you a bad idea is a game track I
think they're trying to force a Supreme
Court decision
oh no that's exactly what the Alabama
thing is like that's very calculated
because they're they gonna sue and now
that suing is gonna go all the way
there's a Supreme Court and here's the
precedent and then this will really say
where we are as a nation you have a
conservative Minari at majority and yeah
but you know what I don't I still have
faith in the system like I don't think
people go that long in the judicial
system to be like a judge a lawyer you
how many times are there but they've
already been conservatives have turned
Kavanagh voted very liberally first of
all Kavanagh is not a terrible guy I
think he I think what happened to him
was like unfair yeah so I think that was
unfair and you know Sarah I think it was
it was a witch hunt I mean that 400
years old that four hundred page report
said a lot about that that they haven't
put that out and they really had an
impeccable record there was absolutely
no history of him Pete predators have a
history there's a long trail he had he's
had an impeccable record up until then
and this woman and this seem terribly
stable and it's temperament they kept
talking about but my pushback on that is
always like let's say this is let's say
he did it yeah let's don't let's say no
let's say he didn't do it he didn't do
it yeah and he's now been accused of
this while he's are trying to go for the
the greatest job in his profession I
would be upset let's say did it yeah and
now he's up on this thing and he's gonna
lose a great either way he's gonna be
exactly the same person he wasn't 16 as
he is now that's another question or any
of us and and the other thing is but I
think
was really a question of a lot of people
especially women with just people in
general including myself we're very
afraid that the wrong justice a
conservative yeah yeah what two of the
women hanging out said they were lying
yes but what's gonna come on the court
but it's happened already in a Flynn and
overturn roe v-- wade and I understand
that and I and I think sometimes you go
you know what I'm gonna fight dirty and
I see a little opening here I'll do
whatever I can to get this [ __ ]
to get a liberal justice or someone
who's pro-choice that I know is
pro-choice on that that's that's some
things are worth fighting for get you
you know slightly but I mean it's like
it's such a but you know what I think
we're missing in the world and right now
is nuanced on an issue like you nobody
looks at things it's everything so black
and why yeah but never the abortion
issue was not black excited I was black
and whites forced on you and when a
presidential candidate is heard saying I
grabbed him by the [ __ ] and he's
rewarded for it see we're all as men
we're all gonna pay for that
collectively we haven't even paid I mean
it should be no surprise that it's not
it's not that women are angry they're
afraid yeah yeah yeah if you let tariffs
I felt like a euphemism though like
Missouri and Alabama like passing the
most restrictive abortion laws on the
planet in the name of you know whatever
that was fear to do I'm fine man yeah it
is surprised that it's Alabama though
are you surprised in Alabama now all
they seem to be but you know there is a
evangelical you know a strong
evangelical but what is that gonna mean
for people over there are people gonna
move out of Alabama is that what's gonna
happen this will be a fight as it always
is yeah but this thinking isn't it did
they make it a law already well but
remember that states are always under
federal jurisdiction so so a state may
pass a law but the federal government
can always come in and say well they're
in this particular federal government's
not gonna do that though that's why
they're gonna that's why they're gonna
sue it's gonna be a fight it's gonna go
all the way to the Supreme Court
yeah well that's what they're trying
then we'll see where we are in the world
it's very scary I mean it's gonna be
these are will
just crazy Tommy people with deeply held
religious convictions that you are
killing a human life that you're killing
an innocent baby mm-hmm and that's how
they feel they have a strong argument
you know scientifically and morally I
suppose for that I say that as somebody
who's pro-choice because I actually
think that a woman's right to choose to
supersede that at least until yes but
what aren't sister would take this up
but what I'm saying is like like this
one I'm talking about with nuance you
know it's also okay the two things can
be worked two things can be true but
we're just saying that let's not put a
moral value on it that's the thing that
I feel about if you had all the time
because because we're feeling we're
feeling people creatures I know but what
I'm saying though is like you know I
believe in Pro - I'm pro-choice - I'm
like little chewed like that women woman
should should choose it still doesn't
mean that like that choice is a great
choice now it's just that we're just
saying that like but you you can make
that choice yeah well that's what I'm
saying so so so I always say I'm saying
you can make sure you should make the
choice in life right let me grant you
that okay so so then all costs and all
costs human life should be preserved and
I love that I love that really nice
sentiment yeah I just really feel really
thing is I don't think it's just
religious I would I wasn't its it
someone put it on has its roots probably
and get it but but it's but I think that
that would be like a but no but the idea
that all human life is sacred is a
religious idea right so in other words
severely [ __ ] a severely handicapped
person and and then an unborn child
these are not and then Eric Griffin the
idea that they are the same war [ __ ]
marry kill
oh my god but when you when you start
talking about how those those lives are
all of the same moral worth yeah now
you're talking about religion the only
way to prove that is with I get you so
as a bit of what I'm saying is that if
you really are if you're that way okay I
respect that but if you are that
concerned with innocent human life lower
the speed limit to 25 miles now
everywhere and make the penalty for
going above it life in prison
well what you'll do is you'll save
probably fifty four thousand lives a
year yeah
innocent lives children a lot of
children too you want texting and
driving that God why don't we do that
and a gun why don't we do that all the
kind of stuff put me out and make all
guns illegal because even if you're
pro-gun make all guns illegal you
something will die of knives and by car
and all that [ __ ] you know murderers
will kill terrorists will find ways but
let's just make all this you'll save a
couple lives right so so what we willing
to do all these things ya know we put a
price on human life all the time
yeah because it's it's part of what life
is now I'm not willing I am not ready I
can't I can't tell a woman a woman cuz
I'm not a woman what to do with her body
again in rape and incest yeah I'm with
you one on rapist bad didn't understand
that one I I just that was like one
because we're dealing with religious
that that part about that part about it
really was like that's a real [ __ ] you
that's that's like a spy a lot of that's
a real [ __ ] left-wing dude here pass
by either why bunch of straight white
men but that I'd be like hey
[ __ ] yeah what I heard I was
like that's a hard one that's how hard
pill to swallow but look but basically
though my point about it is is that you
know we're we're it's Muddy Waters like
it's like you know you're picking the
lesser of two evils in the city in a
situation you know like like Rogan said
on his podcast it's messy yeah abortion
is a messy topic man and I don't feel
comfortable with it I don't I feel like
I'm calm I'm I feel like walking
contradictions yes I feel confused i I
just I
it's like immigration to I don't know
what to do with these children I don't
know what to do with them I don't know
I don't but by the way you say that was
watching you one night and just I you
just off handle and I just love how you
said it just because you were talking
about the subject you just offhand at
least about the wall and everything you
were like you know hey guys you know
y'all have doors and you have locks on
them so if you don't you don't believe
in door borders at all take the front
door off your house yeah
yeah exactly have we all believe in
borders yeah but it was just the way you
said it was just sort of like you know
it was a little it was a little mr. poke
little pokes at 11:00 without their yeah
you know it's just people very but in
pointing out his hypocrisy I acknowledge
the left too and in that you know I
believe in boards but I'd be a shitty
border control agent I'm too emotional
so I'm not consistent right but in the
same way I wouldn't work at our
children's burn Hospital thought I
couldn't do it holy [ __ ] that you're an
example you know I would I would be a
great example I would be bawling every
day I would be just and if you weren't
and I don't want to be the guy who I
don't want to be a person who knows how
to compartmentalize FBI profilers to
deal with the worst crimes right so I'm
saying it takes a certain what the thing
is I don't think we need a wall isn't
technology to the point where we can
have camera systems and and drones
flying all the time we do and I don't
understand what they're talking about do
we can't we have infrared drones and how
do you build a wall over the Rio Grande
a lot of property rights for the wall
thing it's like you know what Jason that
I think is like weird about Trump and
how people respond to him when is the
last time we've had a president that
actually is trying to fulfill his
campaign promises he is understand it's
the kind of weird I don't kid people
thought I was kidding
yeah I don't kid thank you for your vote
excuse me excuse me excuse me excuse me
the important thing is the American
people agree with me he's literally
trying to fulfill campaign promises and
people have a problem with that I just
think it's weird you know I just think
it's like it's a weird it lends itself
to us to think that like you know we
should really be safe
listening to campaign promises and at
that point be like it's just really what
we want like you know is it he's easy
but everything's politicized
he's going to get rehired I would put
money on it bro I would put money if
there was a vaguest thing I'd put money
to he's gonna get reelected so unless
the Democrats find a way to go let's
just pick someone [ __ ] all this primary
stuff let's stop fighting each other cuz
all we're doing is lit it's just you
know promise
firing yeah they need to just go let's
skip all this you right we're gonna put
all our detention behind you no matter
who that is you know what I mean so I
don't know where we I love is yeah I can
talk to you all day I know I got a low
kind of get going I okay no no this is
it Wow we've been here too long yeah
kung fu class all right well you know
what man I'm gonna call this BC part one
you know I'll come back let me your work
ten minutes away for me yeah this is
great
because then we'll just have like
this'll be will do I'm coming I'm
fighting kid yeah I'm gonna be on them
Wednesday this will come but I would
have already been on fire indicate when
this comes out well I want to do I love
to I love doing this with you yeah let's
do it more often man I will look I
appreciate your brain
I appreciate it like you need your
thoughtfulness and how you think about
things like I don't like its people are
too quick to be like when you say
something oh you're a right-wing nut or
you're a left wing nut or you're such a
man or this and that there's nuance to
what we're talking about right now and I
appreciate that about what you're saying
we're missing new ones you know what
nuance is it's the difference between
body positivity and delusion beautiful
that's the nuance right there like am i
a fat ass or or should I feel good about
myself
Craig that's the nuance and we need more
of that in the world yeah yeah nuance is
is it's a it's a shapeshifter
yes you need to be a shape-shift yes
nuances nuance moves with with what's in
front of you and the truth yeah the
truth it sometimes is a river there are
multiple truth of truth like there are
fixed truths of course but there there's
also like sometimes the situation on the
ground changes man that this is what
that's my point about these things
change
she ready you know you have to be ready
for that chain look look at
relationships yes there's a certain
point in a relationship where I loved
you look man now I don't beings are a
verb we are all works in progress I have
arrived
you know I don't have any more work to
do on myself I think your listeners
understand that I hope they learn
everything I think they did you know
what and that's what we're gonna end
there this is the the great Bryan Callen
and I want to thank everybody for
listening to Griffin with Griffin make
sure you hit the subscribe button and
like and look out for a Brian to come
back on cuz he definitely will this has
been riffing with Griffin thanks a lot
and I'll see you next week
[Applause]
[Music]